hal a donné sa vie à grisolles que ça on
est morte l'autre est fait c'est grave
valérie verhée a perdu sa collègue ils
sont amis la première préposés aux
bénéficiaires tombés au combat
victoria salle vannes qui travaillait
dans la zone rouge du ch et celle des
graisses duct face à face avec la coved
c'est pratiquement inévitable les
conditions de travail aussi à doivent
être fatigué brûler des lots des doubles
on manque royalement de personnel c'est
ces mêmes puces et même plus vivable des
employés à bout de souffle qui multiplie
les quarts de travail mais qui ne sont
pas invincibles face à l'ennemi ni face
à la peur moi j'ai envoyé mes enfants
ailleurs de chez moi pour être sûr que
tout le monde est en sécurité fait que
je veux pas oui ça fait pas et demander
à cette préposée aux bénéficiaires qui
est-ce qui l'a rassuré mais nous on n'a
pas des m21 95 euros notre protection
est minimale à comparer peut-être les
hôpital comme on pourrait dire on fait
ce qu'on peut
sinon ma ce qu'on a mais est-ce que
c'est assez pour protéger on sait pas ce
que ça c'est pour protéger nos passés on
sait rien de la maladie en tant que
telle le débat sur les masques n95 est
toujours vif parce que rares sont les ch
et celle d où ils sont disponibles alors
que c'est là où la crise frappe le plus
violemment le n95 et peut-être des
circonstances particulières on parle de
100 intense effet l'urgence
le syndicat des préposés et le cius de
l'ouest de l'île affirme que les
employés ont tous les équipements qui
leur faut mais aujourd'hui à gries date
une demande était affiché dans la
fenêtre adressée à monsieur le goût et
les préposés c'est allemands les plus
proches des résidents c'est ce qui met
leur vie en péril leur protection doit
être prioritaire sur les 2000 préposés
aux bénéficiaires du siucq de l'ouest de
l'île de montréal une centaine sont
atteintes de lakovic 19 issigeac ou de
richard ii n'aurait du canada
mon rêve